they got some good caramelization on
them that cheese crisp is everything you
want to have something at that table
that's going to make them say wow i
think this is it hey everyone it's
takiyah so we all know tic tac has
become the hub for viral food trends
these recipes look like they're quick
they look like they're easy and they
even look like they taste good but is
that true so today i'll be making a
three-course dinner using viral recipes
i found on tiktok and i'll be judging
them according to taste difficulty level
and the time it takes to cook let's see
what you got tic-tac
so every three-course meal begins with
an appetizer and today we'll be making
tic tocs smashed brussels sprouts
personally i think brussels sprouts are
terrible
let's see if this trend is what i've
been missing so we're gonna start with a
pot of salted boiling water and we're
just gonna add our brussels to them
so we have about a pound of brussels
sprouts here and we're pretty much just
gonna boil these for about eight to ten
minutes until they're bright green and
tender
and they look great we are going to add
these to a baking sheet lined with paper
towel just to blot them dry so that when
we put them in the oven they roast and
they don't steam
so we want to get off all of that extra
moisture we'll plot these dry and then
we'll transfer them to a baking sheet
lined with parchment paper
now we're going to start to season our
brussels sprouts we have some olive oil
here that we're gonna drizzle over we
also have some salt
some red pepper flakes for a little bit
of heat and some garlic powder toss
these together so they're nice and
coated i mean these actually look kind
of good i won't lie i think they are
headed in the right direction now we're
gonna smash them you can use a glass cup
a canned good anything heavy we're just
gonna apply some pressure
it looks so much easier in the tic-tac
videos
why aren't these
smashing so let's try to smash this
little guy
that looks pretty good
so i'm gonna try a little bit of a
different strategy with the rest of them
and i'm gonna use this cup to smash
hopefully
this will work
[Music]
all right you know i think i'm being a
little too gentle here
i would make these you know just for fun
just to relieve some tension
so now we're gonna put these in the oven
at 425 and let them roast for about 15
minutes before adding our finishing
touches so our brussels are out of the
oven and they look delicious
time for the best part of the cheese
we're using parmesan here and
we're just gonna go crazy with it
all right so these look amazing they're
nice and cheesy just like i like them
we're gonna bake these for three to five
minutes until they're crispy melty and
hopefully delicious alright so here are
our finished brussels sprouts
we have a smoky yogurt dip to serve it
with just greek yogurt some garlic
paprika salt lemon juice and a little
bit of water to loosen it up i think
these look amazing they're crispy that
cheese just looks so delicious let's try
it
i'm pleasantly
surprised they're super tender but
there's that crisp from the cheese
so for taste on these
i'll do it a minus
difficulty these were super easy to make
time we literally made this dish in
under 30 minutes all right tic tac
you're off to a good start let's see
what else you got so moving on to our
entree we'll be making honeycomb pasta
and i know you guys have seen this trend
all over tik tok where they take
rigatoni noodles you line them up in a
spring pan you fill them with cheese and
you top it with more cheese and you bake
it in the oven we'll be doing our own
version of that today with vodka sauce
we have some olive oil in a pan heating
up and we're going to add in some
pancetta and we're just going to saute
this until it is crispy so it should
take about three to four minutes so all
that fat has rendered out and it smells
so good in here so we're now gonna add
in some diced onion
and let that saute and soften
with that pancetta
so we'll let this go for another three
to five minutes until the onions are
softened and translucent all right so
this looks beautiful we're gonna go
ahead and add some garlic red pepper
flakes so the reason we want to add the
red pepper flakes in now is because
it'll have a chance to bloom in the oil
and infuse the sauce with spiciness
rather than having pockets of spicy
flavor just about 30 seconds
and then we'll go ahead and add
our vodka whoa
[Applause]
cook this until it is mostly evaporated
and if you don't have vodka feel free to
skip it it'll still be a delicious sauce
so it looks like our vodka has
evaporated pretty nicely add in some
crushed tomatoes
heavy cream stir this and let it simmer
for about 10 minutes until thickened so
while that's cooking let's make our
filling i've seen this recipe done a
bunch of different ways and today we've
decided to fill our rigatoni with
ricotta so we have some ricotta here and
some mozzarella cheese we also have some
parmesan cheese some garlic powder dried
basil and some salt we're gonna mix this
all together
and that'll be our filling our ricotta
mixture is a little firm as you can see
um and we did that intentionally because
we want it to stay inside of the
rigatoni and not seep out when it bakes
our ricotta filling is made so now it's
time to assemble this whole dish we're
going to start with a cup of our vodka
sauce
and put that
on the bottom of the springform pan
we'll just evenly coat it
now for our rigatoni we've cooked these
al dente
so we'll line our springform pan
with the rigatoni until it's completely
full
these are stuck together so that helps
i'm just concerned about whether it's
gonna stay standing once we remove it
from the spring form hopefully it
doesn't just like melt into a pile of
pasta all right we're getting there i
will say it is pretty and i guess that's
what tic tac's all about like making
aesthetically pleasing dishes
i did it all right let's start piping
we'll fit our tip into the rigatoni
and slowly squeeze in some of that
filling
only 50 more to go
whoever made this recipe had some time
on their hands so we have our last
couple rigatoni we finally finished
filling
our pasta we're gonna pour the rest of
our homemade vodka sauce onto the top
we'll spread that all over
okay
we'll finish this off with some fresh
torn mozzarella cheese
and i will say this smells amazing right
now
all right we're gonna go place this in
the oven for about 25 to 30 minutes
until it's heated through and then see
if it was worth all of the fuss so our
honeycomb pasta is out of the oven we
let it cool for about 20 to 30 minutes
to let it set a little better and now
for the moment of truth
let's see if she stands
she's standing wow like this is actually
very pretty it's
very aesthetically pleasing adding some
fresh torn basil on top
and
there she is our honeycomb pasta let's
cut into this and see if it tastes good
i think it'll stay together i i think
it's gonna stay
here we go
uh-oh
uh-oh
i mean we got something yeah i do think
it was pretty difficult to plate um and
you lose a lot of the hard work you put
in by plating it because it kind of just
falls apart let's hope the taste is
there all right here goes nothing
make sure i get some of that rigatoni
got that ricotta kind of shooting out
which is nice
[Music]
it's definitely good like
solid pasta dish for sure but i don't
think there's anything special it tastes
the same if you mix it in a pot as far
as taste definitely give this an a i
think it was delicious difficulty in
time enough it took too long i'm not
sure if it's worth it we have one more
dish to make and that is dessert so
let's do it today we're going to be
making a creme brulee and the cool thing
about this recipe is it's only three
ingredients
one of the ingredients is ice cream so
we're going to be using butter pecan ice
cream today to make our creme brulee
so we'll put about a half of a cup into
a bowl
and then we'll just melt this in the
microwave
our ice cream is melted now we're going
to add one egg yolk and we'll whisk that
until it's combined and that is our
creme brulee batter it's literally just
that so we're going to transfer this to
a ramekin that we have inside of a
baking dish
just pour that in
and now we're going to fill this dish
with some hot water just halfway up the
side of the ramekin we're gonna bake
this in the oven at 325 for about 25
minutes until it's set but still a
little bit jiggly then we're gonna chill
it in the refrigerator for two hours
so our creme brulee has been baked and
it's chilled for two hours and look at
it it actually looks like a creme brulee
i'm pretty shocked this was ice cream
and an egg yolk so now what's a creme
brulee without that crunchy sugar top
we're gonna go ahead and add some sugar
to the top of this creme brulee and
torch it we actually can't do this in
studio so now we're gonna take this
outside and finish it up
we're back in the studio and now we're
gonna finish this up with our garnishes
i'm just gonna pipe some little dollops
of whipped cream on here
and we're also going to garnish with
some candied pecans so i'll just
sprinkle those around
you can hear that sugar
and there it is our beautiful three
ingredient butter pecan creme brulee
and that sugar
it does look like creme brulee
[Music]
so taste i think it was pretty close to
a traditional creme brulee but not quite
there so b plus
difficulty level super easy to make so a
for that time it did take about two
hours for it to chill i might give it
like a d it it just took too long so we
just got done making a three course meal
using only tick tock inspired recipes
overall i did learn some pretty cool
hacks and i will try a couple of these
again if there are any other tic tac
recipes you want us to try let us know
in the comments and we will thanks for
watching
you